what i want to do in this video is think
a little bit about how the unemployment
rate is actually computed by the bureau
of labor statistics so to figure that
out let's just start off with the entire
u.s population so let me draw a big
circle here that represents the entire
u.s population
u.s population
population and right now if my numbers
are correct the latest numbers are
304 million people
now not all of those 304 million people
are capable of working including my two
and a half year old son or my my my
newborn daughter so you have to think
about when you think about unemployment
you want to think about the percentage
of these people that are actually old
enough to work that actually can be
employed theoretically so let's take a
subset of that u.s population and let's
think about who's essentially an adult
whose working age so this subset right
over here is 16 years
and older so people who can legally work
and the numbers i have here that this is
100
sorry this right here is
237 million people
237 million people
now we can't just say all of these
people are could possibly work because a
lot of them are in college some of them
are in high school some of them might
not have the ability to work some of
them might be retired so we want to just
take a subset of this population that is
essentially you could say part of the
labor force in that they are working or
they are actively looking for work so
let me draw that right over here
so this right over here
is the labor force
labor force so these are not retirees or
people who are in college those people
would be sitting right over there
assuming they're 16 years or older the
labor force so this is
working
or or i should say working and actively
looking for work and we'll think about
what actively looking for work means in
a little bit more depth in a few minutes
actively looking
actively looking for
work
and that number if my numbers are
correct is right around 154 million
although the numbers here aren't so
important the more important thing is
the idea of how the unemployment rate
itself is calculated and then so within
the labor force you have a subset so
this is working and actively looking for
work so you have a subset of the of the
labor force that is actively looking for
work so they don't have a job but
they're actively looking so this right
here
is unemployed
unemployed
unemployed and actively looking
actively looking this actively looking
is probably more
important than you might realize at
first and this number let's just say for
the sake of argument this is sitting at
around 15 million people
15 million people so if you have a job
you're right over here if you don't have
a job but are actively looking you are
going to be right over here what we're
going to see in a little bit is if you
have if you don't have a job but you are
not actively looking but you could be
working you could you would actually be
sitting out here and this is going to be
interesting when we think about trends
and the unemployment rate when it goes
up or down but just to see how the
unemployment rate is calculated let's
use do it for this example so the
unemployment rate
unemployment rate
employment
rate
is literally is literally just the
number of unemployed over the entire
labor force so in this situation it
would be 15 million
so that's just the number of unemployed
and actively looking over the entire
labor force
over
154 million and so if we get if i get my
handy ti 85 out that gives us in this
example right over here an unemployment
rate of 15 divided by
154
million so it's about 9.7
if we if we write it as a decimal
0.097 if we write it as a percentage
this would be 9.7 percent so this is
this is approximately
9.7 percent now i told you that the
details are going to be important and
the reason why they are is because
interesting things happen when people
stop looking for work or when they start
looking for work
so i said unemployed and actively
looking puts you in this bucket over
here if you're unemployed if you don't
have a job and you're not actively
looking you're actually not in the labor
force and so you might be saying sal
what does it mean to be actively looking
for work and this means that you've
looked for a job or you're actively
searching in the past
let me do this in a new color
in the past four weeks
past four weeks and you might say sal
how do you know how do they know whether
these 15 million people are have
actively searched for jobs in the past
four four weeks and the answer is they
do a survey they're not going to survey
every human being in the labor force or
the u.s population or all 15 million
that are unemployed that would be
logistically impossible what they do is
they do a survey and right now they do
about 60 000 people every month and they
essentially ask them are you employed
are you unemployed if you are unemployed
have you looked for a job in the past
four weeks if you have looked for a job
in the past four weeks and an unemployed
person you get thrown into this bucket
right here you're actively looking
you're still part of the labor force but
if you've gotten so discouraged that
you're no longer looking for work maybe
you've given up
then you get thrown out of here you get
thrown into you get thrown out of the
labor force and that is what i think
most people don't realize if things get
bad enough and people get really
discouraged you have people not going
not you have people actually exiting the
entire labor force and see how that
affects the numbers imagine a situation
so this is the unemployment rate right
now there's 15 million people who are
unemployed and actively looking for work
let's say that this is just a horrible
recession or depression and five million
of these people get so discouraged they
they don't they don't in the last four
weeks they do not look for work anymore
so they maybe even stopped altogether or
they want to take a break so what we're
going to do is we're going to take 5
million people out of this bucket over
here so we're going to take 5 million
people and move them out
over here outside of the labor force if
you did that what happens well now the
number the official unemployed number is
now going to be 10 million
it's now going to be 10 million and
what's the labor force number remember
they went completely out of this green
circle over here so they also left the
labor force so the labor force number is
now
149 million so in this in this bad
situation where people have left the
labor force the unemployment rate would
now be 10 million people unemployed and
actively looking for work over a labor
force of
149 million the labor force has shrunk
because they're so discouraged so what
do we get there's our unemployment rate
we have 10
divided by
149
it gives us
6.7 percent
so this is this is fascinating if things
get bad enough and people actually exit
the labor force then the unemployment
rate could go down because the labor
force is shrinking
the other thing could also happen maybe
things get really good maybe things get
really good and you have 10 million
people who are sitting out here 10
million people sit who are sitting out
here they're either marginally attached
workers which are people who have who
are hoping to get a job but haven't
looked for a job in the past four weeks
or they could be discouraged workers
who've all together they wouldn't mind
working but they've given up all
together looking but you can imagine it
when the economy gets good let's say
we're starting from this baseline here
the economy gets good and all of these
people who are unemployed but not part
of the labor force always start all of a
sudden start looking for work
so then they'd be part of the official
unemployed so this 10 million would grow
to 20 million
20 million
so now this number is 20 million and
this green area would go up by 10
million so now this would be 159 million
so in this situation the official
unemployed would be 20 million
and the entire labor force would be 159
million
and now you would get a situation
so you have 20
divided by 159 million which is 12.6
percent
12.6 percent approximately 12.6 percent
so the whole point of this video i'm not
saying that the unemployment rate is the
way it's calculated is wrong or that
it's supposed to be misleading i just
want to give you a little bit of nuance
that it doesn't always give the complete
picture in particular that one number
justice and there's there's other
unemployment rates that give a little
bit more nuance here but this this one
headline unemployment rate that's
typically given on the news doesn't
capture the whole story and in
particular it doesn't capture the people
who might be exiting the labor force
when things are bad so in that situation
the unemployment rate would probably be
understating the how bad things are and
it also doesn't capture the people who
are entering the labor force and that
situation the unemployment rate would
probably make things look worse than
they are when things might actually be
improving